[Music]
yeah i guess we can just start
i'm um my name is jared williams
i'm the
co-founder and current director of
lion's draw festival which is an
annual um experimental performance and
dance festival
that's based in boston massachusetts
cambridge massachusetts um this is
uh unseated nipmuck wampanoag and uh
massachusetts territory and um
that those territories also cover the
location of
massachusetts institute of technology
mit
which is uh co-hosting this event and
um like many of you uh we were
you know we've been deeply affected by
the pandemic
and this was going to be our inaugural
year
um with mit and we were very excited
and they've just been incredibly
supportive
um through this weirdness
and um we're very grateful for
this collaboration and looking forward
to it continuing so
um yeah susan wilson
um and jay shive are you know two of the
people we've been working with susan's
here and we'll say a few words in a
second
um i just want to thank
um thomas de france and jupiter poe and
joy mariama smith who stayed up late to
be with us here today
um super excited these have been so
beautiful
and um i'm sure this one will be too so
again we might have some time for
questions at the end
but otherwise um i'll just keep handed
over to susan
thanks jerry just really quickly um we
wanted to say how
honored and grateful we are to be able
to be putting this on with all of you
wonderful people
um we of course like jared really much
wish that we could be doing this
in person and hopefully next year we
will be able to um mit performing is a
collaboration with the mit's music and
theater arts department
and the center for art science and
technology and we're hoping to bring
more of these kinds of collaborations in
this upcoming
weird bizarre hopefully inspiring season
um and with that i will just give it
straight over to the incomparable
educator and artist
tommy different thank you
susan um i have my candle
so that we can start in easy with a
grounding gesture
and um i broadcast
today from durham north carolina where i
live
and labor and um
the space where i broadcast from
sits on ancestral lands of the chicory
the ino and the catawba people
it's been a remarkably complex
emotional journey through this version
of the lions jaw festival this year
and i think these entanglements will
continue
certainly for me for quite some time
today i'm really happy to be talking to
beings who i have known for a little
while
and i want to bring in in this
acknowledgement
i have eight great nephews so three of
my
nephews and nieces have children and
they have eight
boys between them and i want to bring
these boys
in to be with us today because i want
them to have the queer possibility
that we all might want for each other um
and i'm thinking about them
and wondering alongside them with us
here today so i'll
go to our our panelists that asks you
um what you'd like to acknowledge as we
begin our conversation
and of course how shall you be how shall
you prefer to be addressed
by others today or this evening
dream a tattoo will you
yes i will i think maybe we want to race
not to go first between enjoy and meet
[Laughter]
um greetings everybody i'm juma tattoo
right now i am located in my brother's
car which i have been driving while he's
been in uh
well he's been in brazil i
am normally in
saki mao ching ing also called
philadelphia
um right now i am on canarsie land
actually
at the canarsie pier um
in brooklyn the
i had to come up to
new york from philly to date for for a
couple of different reasons
and i'm here now and i thought about
being outside
and i just wanted to be next to the
water and so
i am i wanted to bring you all closer to
the water but
it's you get to see my brother's car and
me
um and so i'll bring
i'll bring my brother with me here which
i normally do my siblings
i'm the oldest of five siblings that
share the same parents
and i also have three others uh from my
father
and not my mother and um i typically i
tend to bring them with me
uh whether i like it or not it feels
like
if anybody on here knows any of my
siblings you probably know what i mean
by that
um and
i'd like to bring in those those people
to whom i'm an ancestor i want to bring
them those ones that i haven't met yet
who i'm excited to meet and to never
meet
um
my uh the in writing i'll usually always
usually always what is that i tend to go
i tend to use my name
my pronouns fluctuate from environment
to environment
i invite you to to call out whatever
you're called to i'll let you know
if i needed to change
um
hi can you repeat the question
hey it's a chat
it was like how you be where you be
what you be how you feel you
okay um
i am in
more than one place at once
uh i i feel like
my part of my energetic body
is in philadelphia
uh
because that's where i was born so
sort of sort of plus one to
juma part parts of juma's sentiments
um and then part of my energetic body is
somewhere else probably in space like
i definitely feel like i'm not
present somehow um
which is
yeah i guess putting me on a different
level
and feeling
um yeah already grappling with the fact
that i'm
in the
netherlands and it's dark
uh
that feels strange because i'm like
uh i think like this is the first
moment that i've been on a panel with
people that i
know and i'm deeply connected with that
are where i am from and
all of the ways i guess uh so that is
an interesting feeling
um but i
i know that i contain multiplicities and
complexities so that's fine
um i was thinking about how
i would like to be addressed
um and that's always fun to answer
i think so what popped into my head
was the honorable joy mariana smith
um or like queen
um
i also really like pet names
specifically having to do with desserts
so
cupcake or sweetie but
really don't do that if you're not
feeling it because
i will know um pronoun wise
you can use the english neutral ones
i don't actually know how mixed
linguistically uh the group is
but where i am there's a lot of
languages that
don't have neutral pronouns
and in that case you can always use my
name
um joy or if you want to practice
um recognizing blackness you can say
blackjoy
yes please so those that's an elaborate
answer but all those things
are allowed and
i think just to reiterate uh
i like this phrase
when i when i like talk to my ancestors
of uh especially when i'm asking for
help or trying to figure something out
that i that i name the ancestors that i
know
the ancestors that i don't know and the
ancestors that know me better than i
know myself
so i want to holler at those
that triad
and i think that's it
that's terrific to kind of help us
pivot and um i was thinking
about how we began each of these three
three sessions of this you know the
queer futures lions jaw
with this you know trying to have this
gentle acknowledgement space
but then this question about at address
as well and and there it is about a
certain kind of consent
you know like what is it to be in a
relationship where people
somehow agree on in some way
and i hadn't really framed it that way
in my
sort of consciousness until i was
thinking of you
black joy because i know this is
something you work on
and um juma tattoo i've witnessed
jumatatsu in creative craft be
incredibly diligent about consent
and you know as as bipac folk black folk
the three of us like
maybe we could think about that together
a little bit
how does consent sort of manifest
in our our black queer possibilities or
we can remove the labels
since it's the three of us we can be as
as nasty as we want to be among each
other
without having to be sort of compiled
into
five or eight identities as you say joy
the many identities that we have
um but what about consent let's let's
see if we can start there
i mean do you go into
relationship with terms of consent
do you find them along the way how are
you working with consent these days
me why not thank you
um let's
see
how how am i with consent these days
um i'm not gonna answer that question
because i think it's right now
impossible for me
to answer uh but i
can talk about
where am i with consent these days
um because i've been researching it
actively for a while i think my
life has been uh
a research on consent anyway um
yeah i think like things that are
popping into my head
is um
yeah having a politicized body so moving
away from
labels um but knowing that i have a
politicized body
that's also a performing body that also
is a body that gets a certain gender
projected
onto them all these things
carry complex relationalities with
consent and performance
where um
i'm definitely doing some excavating
around
what that looks like um what's exciting
to me about that
right now because a lot of people um
uh talk about consent and are
sort of walking or talking the talk and
not
walking the walk um again
if someone doesn't understand my like
northeast american
hust slang maybe just put it in the chat
and i'll try to
explain it
this like idea that in practice
i hear a lot of verbage or
vocabulary around consent and then i
don't see
that matching um behaviors
and i have um that's disturbing
um however i was actually trying to say
what i
enjoy and what i do enjoy is that the
people that i'm
in conversation with i'm having really
interesting conversations
primarily with the aid of denise
ferreira da silva who i will shout out
to
um who
who is helping me go back to the the
etymology of this word
which actually means feeling together
and i think
when i stay in that zone um
it's much easier for me to be
with all the complexities
and not like put myself in a box or put
someone else in a box or if we
are in a group uh what is
what is feeling together sensing
together
look like when it's not just one
relationality but multiple
ones and how
i can train
myself to continue to cultivate skills
in feelings
um and i see a question in the chat
but i don't know if i should answer that
right now i see it
let me see yeah we can
you know um we can circle back through
chat later so you don't have to try to
do five things at once
if you want so that's cool yeah thumbs
up
yeah jared will help us with that um a
little bit later
uh yeah
i um joy were you about to say something
oh i see you're muted so
i'm assuming that you were good with
that
um and i like uh thinking about what you
said about the etymology
of the word of consent i don't it's
something
i feel like it's consent is something
that i used to say and talk about a lot
in various practices as an educator
practices as
an organizer practices as an artist
and i don't use the word so much anymore
i think because it's i'm not totally
sure what
what i'm saying when i say it meaning
what it's
the it feels like that that word is so
pervasive
that i don't know what somebody's
hearing when i say it and i don't know
necessarily what they're saying when
they say it to me and when we're talking
about it
which is a space that i'm in a whole lot
i speak um portuguese as well
and it's not you know i i learn i didn't
grow up with portuguese so
there is i feel like i am frequently in
a place of
confusion around around words
and engaging in a whole kind of matrix
of communication
really really accepting that and trying
to
decipher and diffuse things as well
diffuse the
what can feel like the you know the the
the this dacticism of certain words
sometimes
so with consent i feel like uh
which that that no the notion of it and
how i understand it and especially
joy with you introducing that etymology
of it
that feels that feels important to me it
feels like there is something that is
central about
being together about community formation
which feels very central to all to
all of my different works in life and to
my life you know
um i was talking about my family
earlier and i think that seeing myself
in relationship has been something that
has been
super central in my conception of
what it is that i'm doing here you know
here um so
so i think that there is something about
a kind of
there is something about a uh
an ability to invest in the care
and in a certain type of care to be able
to
to risk confusion and to be able to get
lost kind of in the confusion of
communication
that i think i feel like is central to
consent and it also feels like it
for me especially these days i mean it's
not i don't
i feel super choosy about community it's
like you know
i mean i don't so much i don't make
friends so often anymore
um which
feels you know which feels okay and it
feels like there is something about
the intentionality of that kind of
community formation
of the ability to invest in consent with
people that i'm
that i'm interested in and it also
doesn't feel like
i don't feel like i have an infinite
source for that you know so
it feels like um
it feels like i'd like to and i need to
be choosy
about how
how i'm going about that and that also
does you know it
there's lots of instances where that
can't happen and i think it you know it
to to me it gets also very messy
you know this um how to how to deal with
that
how to deal with permissions and
boundaries and
and um
and feeling and the interpretation of
feeling
and communication of them
yeah but in inside of that something
about
a kind of like shortness
you know we're we're all constrained
under the roma
you know in our our sort of um different
versions of lockdown
different parts of the world where jms
is
as well as quite different from here in
some ways
but yeah i i do also experience this
kind of shortness
of willingness in a way that's quite
different than eight months ago
you know for myself like a willingness
to be
called on to do certain kinds of labor
that we're all called on to do
and we get that um but then also as a
you know someone headed towards queer
maturities of many kinds it's like
there's there's relationships that want
to be developed
and like you know i want to be available
and you know i'm sure you do as a
as an educator and mentor as well to be
available into family
so then you know yeah how
how to make different kinds of
intentional decisions especially now
um so that you can understand your own
energetic flow as well
like that seems big like you being in
the car because you wanted to be near
the water
you know there's something about a a
willingness to care take
um and be available to yourself
and others that that just seems in there
that's enough that that also feels like
a word that
that that word availability good is also
is
something that i that i think about a
lot you know i mean i mentioned before
i i grew up as an oldest sibling
um and the expectation of my
availability yeah feels like it's
been you know it that that's been
something that that that
that i'm accustomed to that i've grown
to understand
as central to my identity you know i
mean it feels
into it feels like i've integrated it it
feels like i've
integrated a capacity to be
available um
there's i don't think you know i was
i mean i i was thinking about maybe
something that came up yesterday in the
this um the the queer futures
something about uh
what is it like the the back something
about
something about oh being able to see
your
i don't know something somehow somebody
said something about bottoming
yeah and i thought about like
receptivity
and just how
thinking about being receptive and being
available
and how
that kind of permeability sharing that
kind of
permeability with someone really sharing
that you know i mean it
i don't i feel super super passionate
about
sex education education in general but i
think that that that that kind of
you know it feels like there's there
there can be these cultural
imperatives to be permeable and to be
imp impenetrable um though those kinds
of
those kinds of dichotomies and it feels
like i spend a lot of time
trying to understand availability
receptivity being permeable
which i have a d i have a deep
appreciation for it and
i think you know like i was saying about
with you know investing in consent
it doesn't feel that doesn't feel like
something that's infinite it feels like
that i love to make a choice to be
available
because it feels like there's a lot of
gravity in that because i know that i'm
using up something in myself you know
hopefully that can be replenished but
you know i mean that's a it's a lot
to be really be receptive
no yeah that i mean that availability
that is like
that feels like a huge huge
yeah very close hi this is an asl
interpreter can we take like a
minute because we're having some
technical like difficulties right now
yes please we'll take a moment to to set
they reset
i think now we figured it out so there
we go
thank you hercules hey no problem joy
you there
yes
i mean to be honest i was just thinking
about how sometimes i do
queer cardio and i play a lot of justin
bieber
and i like
uh
this the justin bieber has a song called
available
that's really good to do cardio too um
but when i
i i have a very sort of vivid moment
of the last time i was allowed to be
in a room with a group of people
sweating and yelling
um which was a privilege
uh that
i was doing you know
heavily influenced by jane fonda and
richard simmons
uh just just to sort of
uh date myself but not too much
um i i i was doing these arm movements
and talking about like
the arms being extensions of the sternum
and
availability
um so i'm i mean i'm definitely like a
witch so i'm definitely trying to like
do some spell work
through the the harm
the harmless guys of justin bieber and
like
uh you know inceptioning some some queer
messaging
uh but i think like
i would i hear and i don't even know
like i'm very bad at
perceiving things through screens like
so
but i'm just gonna pretend like the the
what i perceived from joomla this vibe
of like
how we took a journey from
um
consent to availability
and what i would i felt super aligned
with
that i may be projecting but like maybe
not
jimmy you can tell me is the weight of
a black body and with like
availability like i actually can't even
right now especially in
corona it's like um
where
yeah i'm not i'm also going to like
sidestep availability
and also not link it to
bottoming and receptiveness um
as uh
a person with a [ __ ] like i think
there's
many ways to be receptive and many ways
to bottom and many ways to top
and sometimes it has to do with how
available you are and
sometimes not um
[Music]
but i did want to talk about boundaries
um what do you have to say about it over
there in the lab
cause you're laughing tommy so you know
i know there's something behind this
i see you yeah i don't have a form
thought
um but this idea of boundaries
and consent i'm just thinking about how
we you know each of the three of us and
our multiplicities are
called on to do so much work about
helping others understand boundaries or
availability and i'm thinking of all the
times i've been
told i was unavailable or
you know like just had too much attitude
and i don't i mean i know i get it
and it's like having to double do the
labor
of the boundary and the consent and the
availability
because um something that's so lovely
about how jhuma tattoo was was
tilting us back through family and
family is one kind of
relationality and sometimes it's so
[ __ ] up and sometimes it's amazing
and then there's chosen family and birth
fat like you know we had different
constructions of family but that's
really different from kind of making
making worlds and
the spaces where um you know kind of
imagine speculative imagination
and then you know all around this
question of what's allowed
for you know for folks who are
moving through spaces of black queerness
you know there's this
you know this constant question of
what's allowed where's the boundary
you know where's it gonna be unavailable
or you better stop
for all kinds of reasons and that's why
i'm laughing because um as i brought
those little great nephews in the room
um i remember one of my little nephews
was looking at a photograph that was on
the wall
um where i live and he was like why is
that guy naked
and i was like because that guy's
amazing and
i didn't really have like you know he's
like four um
but then the little boy was like i don't
think he should be naked and i was like
well why do you say that
you know like what's why don't we let's
look at his body
and let's let's be together in this sort
of contemplation
um but there was this question that
about my brother
who's who's great you know who's whose
son it is or my nephew whose son it is
and and all of that sort of thing so
yeah i went a lot of different
directions there
do i wear to that did that help at all
what that laugh was
oh i mean yeah totally i just thought of
something else
around um
availability and boundaries and consent
and um i can't
how you just phrased it with this little
one who's four
the way that you said some phrase that
you were like
being available to this little person to
to con you said something about being
together in contemplation
i think and
um somehow that was linked to
availability and also like
whatever capital or bandwidth or
spoons for people that uh
know what spoons are i give a shout out
to you
um where this negotiation
of yeah can i
can i be with you in contemplation on
something
is definitely a huge question
i am asking um
all the time almost these days
um and i just read my horoscope
and apparently that's what i'm supposed
to be doing
so i can take stock and balance and
reset like
where i need to be putting energy into
something so that i don't burn out
because i'm trying to
do whatever survive or whatever um
so i think i'm i think that's actually
pretty interesting um
to just pause for a moment and think
who who we are able to be
in a moment a contemplative moment with
i think is actually a pretty
well you're brilliant tommy so um
[Music]
so yeah i was sort of spacing out
thinking about that
i was around
small people all morning between the
ages of
four and ten um
joy did you say a contemplative moment
is that what you just said a moment ago
yeah because i sort of not like
contemplative dance practice
but yeah yeah which i enjoy sometimes
but like oh
i am in a moment i'm being fully present
and contemplating x
which is how what i sort of extracted
from
tommy's uh looking at this image of this
naked body
then i was like oh damn like when do i
when do i slow down enough to arrive at
a moment where i can be
in contemplation with someone that i
then dragged into contemplative
i mean it's yeah
the i mean you know i think like
so many people i've been feeling
slow i've been
so like so many people i've been feeling
slower
i think that there's uh i feel like
there is something about slow that is
like in my genetic material
um
i remember i think it was maybe when i
was in third grade some one of my
teachers
like the one of my teachers
something that i think i needed more
time on a test or something and then my
one of my teachers
said something like oh why do you why do
you have to be so slow with
everything or something like that you
know and the
some something about that it was
something about how that was
agitating the rhythm of an accelerated
class or something like that i don't
know
you know which has stuck with that that
that
and then also another a kind of
choreographer mentor figure said
something
like uh what did you say
about how my work
they always get surprised at the length
of my work because it always
seems so much longer than what they
realize that it is
and it does feel like there is something
about that kind of
i'm thinking about i mean i'm just
thinking about how the
joy you were connecting this um
slow in contemplation i mean for me for
me that's what i heard
and i think that i agree with the you
know like i think that that
that slow kind of i mean you know the
pace of reflection
to me feels slow um
and it also feels like i was um
i was in north carolina recently uh
with a friend of mine who has two dogs
and being around the i don't have any
pets i didn't grow up with pets and
being
around those dogs who spent you know
92 percent of the day just kind of in a
kind of vegetative
state you know contemplate i you know i
mean i don't know what goes on in that
state but then at the drop of a dime can
just be up
and like act active and agile and
so attentive and i just think about how
you know like those those rhythms of
slow and fast how they work
together i love i love i love to be
fast i love to i love to move fast i
love you know like like like
these this kind of like lightning
lightning
speed uh uh uh realization kind of thing
you know like that kind of phenomenon um
and it feels like that
that slowness has to happen abundantly
in order to
allow for some of those twitchier kinds
of things and that the
the the twitchiness relates that creates
this thing where you know like
where that where that slow can
develop new meanings you know that that
can't be developed in that kind of
twitch
energy but it's the something and
something about being around
these kids too today
about that kind of like i don't know
something about that like the rhythm of
concentration and
focus which felt i don't i don't
know it's it's been so long since i've
been one you know
anyway something something about the way
that those things go together that the
way that that's slow and fast
go together is really is really um
interesting to me the way that that
slowness or you know i mean
there's so much uh kind of cycling about
rest now politics of rest and you know
how that
is related to could support you know
like these these
these these rhythms of of of work you
know um
and i've been i think i think i think a
lot about how
in different communities how our cycles
of work and rest can better
uh support one another
resting so that somebody can work
working so that somebody can rest
um and i don't necessarily like when i'm
saying work i'm not
talking in a nine to five day but you
know i mean i think i do think that
there is
work involved in being this planet you
know there is
labor that i think i think that there is
labor that is a part of the human a
human responsibility
and it also feels like it is supported
best in that you know by abundant
slowness
abundant slowness is just um delicious
and joy i wonder i was thinking about
your
you made an offhand comment about your
sort of
practices of alchemy or or
witching witching and yesterday we were
talking about weathering
um but something about slowness and
witchery or witchiness or not witchiness
but witching
making things um be able to transform
through time being reconfigured that's
i'm trying to connect those ideas
and i just wonder um how your your
practices
of of kind of um
other ways of being if you will you know
i don't know how you
how you characterize horoscope or
or or crafting or spelling making spells
um but something about how they operate
in time with you or how you're thinking
of time
be really curious to hear that oh
um
uh yes
well i recently got a kitten
um and i remember her name's ash
she's black so named after
arthur ashe because arthur ashe
is the first black person i didn't
report on in school for black history
month
also i'm i'm like giving you clues to my
age
what i'm definitely gonna tell you um
and i remember one of my friends
uh like i was like talking about how
ash's personality
as a kitten being a couple months old
being like um she's social
and she very quickly and this also sort
of
uh dovetails into how joomla was talking
about
dogs um
but ash also has ability to be like
totally 100
knocked out relaxed and then can like
pop up and be like
alert which i also think for me is
related to feeling together and consent
and boundaries and availability like
and work rest like i i think they're
that i'm just so blessed to be in this
constellation of thought with y'all
um those visible and those not visible
um but so ash i was talking about like
someone and i was like
i don't really like that person and my
friend was like
well ash is gonna know because she's a
witch's cat like
she'll know and she'll probably behave
in some kind of way
and then i was just kind of like no but
she totally does
like she's still like a kitten and
i think about so this is sort of like
other ways of being i'm using
ash as as we are um in
a relationship that is developing
um we are developing a language we are
figuring out how we be and i think
a lot of times she is my mirror
uh which is wonderful to see
and also helps with my own access to
slowness
um because true stories i'm i tend to
sort of
overdo and do many things at once
so i think when i think about
uh work or like when i do
work in dreams or when i'm
doing using other things
whether they're objects or you know i'm
doing
like i'm a little bit of a rock nerd or
if i'm trying to be intentional in
speech or intentional in writing
or like what is a spell i think
um i have so many different practices
that are i i
that are sort of interwoven
and it really depends on what context
i'm in if i
name that that that's what i'm doing
um because i think part of
it's like okay how many diasporas am i
a part of and being um
of indigenous descent and african
diasporic descent and
some oth some other stuff i mean i'm not
doing any sort of 23andme or whatever
the thing is now
but i also ha
no and i i'm not actually prioritizing
the known over the unknown
um because i value both and in between
and that's also important a part of my
magic
um is sort of conversing and
and entering uh states of unknown
and being okay with that but
that there's also like part of my
heritage
is coming from a place
of alchemy and healing and
and communicating with things
other than human beings and because
that heritage is also diasporic i
definitely have like a
collage or um
pastiche of things that i pick up along
the way
um or things that land in my lap
um that i
i feel out i mean like intuition or
emotional intelligence like
these things i think it's interesting
i think maybe joomla said earlier
uh when they were talking about
speaking portuguese and language and
etymology
that um
one of the main things that i'm
discovering now
especially now that i'm sort of embedded
in some institutions
is i no longer want to
have this hierarchy of language and
certainly not the english language like
sometimes i don't want to prioritize
articulation
verbal articulation um
and sometimes language can dilute or
pollute um some intentions
and sometimes i don't need to be afraid
of
not being able to articulate myself or i
also don't need to be afraid of moments
of silence
where i might just be
there might not be any words that like
formless
thought might be a thing and as an
educator i wonder what kind of
environments
i need to support so that that is also
valued um because
for me now i'm sort of learning and
doing at the same time which
is okay but i i'm like oh in
in my imaginings of the queer futures
it's like uh yeah if we ju if we could
just not like bog
ourselves down with you know if we can
just like
get into the earth and get into the body
and feel the fluids
and yeah like those fluids are actually
good for our brain like
also and so then we can this is also why
when i'm going into theory
i do aerobics first so things can move
around
i mean i've been away from
from juma for quite some time so i don't
know if you have
what you're thinking about over there um
but i guess somehow this is also related
to this
slowness um
or and i'm noticing also
how we are governing this space
of like what compels us to speak like
i there's sometimes we're pausing and
sometimes we're thinking
um are there
are there different ways of
understanding that we're pausing and
thinking
or do we need to say things
it's not a judgment it's just it's
actually just a question to throw out
into the mix with all the other
questions i also want to say something
about
um hercules
uh because for a minute there i couldn't
see
um i couldn't see hercules
and um
[Music]
now i can i can see hercules again and
that
is i don't know i feel really supported
by being able
to i mean in another lifetime i actually
studied
um asl so it actually feels really
supportive to be
in an environment where there is an
interpreter
and to also see
um my voice
in another way and i just want to
express gratitude
for that
i see you i see you
give a tattoo yeah i'm
let's see for some reason i wanted to uh
it's not a story but for some reason i
want to say this and then i'll see
later if it connects i mean i guess it
i i guess it does you know i'm here so
um i remember
oh gosh the there was
you know so it was some kind of like
some some epiphany that i had like
probably my last year
in high school or my first year in
college or something like that where it
was like oh my gosh there's all these
different
past iterations of me that are
running around and like you know being
reiterated through different stories
that other people are telling you know
about something that they remember
of me and i'm just like oh [ __ ] i'm i'm
i'm just i'm different now and you don't
understand and maybe we're not friends
anymore maybe you know maybe i moved
away
i used to move a lot when i was younger
and you know like
leaving i felt like i was leaving all
these different versions of me behind
and it made me feel like very
for like for for for so for some time it
felt like i had to
deal with that kind of dissociation from
myself that it felt like it caused
like all of this spillage
out or something it was just was really
but it felt you know it felt like i it
felt like i didn't have control
and i didn't know that i'd consented to
that you know
and it's um and i feel like it has a lot
to do with the way that i think about
i think it you know what what got me
here
joy was you know when you when you were
kind of extrapolating the magic that you
do
um no sorry i i don't think you
explicitly said the word magic that's
what i heard
um but when you were talking about
witchery when you were talking about
witching
um but i but for me
i think about magic a lot and something
about
how
i guess you i mean how slippery
myself is to hold on to or you know i
have this
i have this kind of like slow partner
dance practice
and thinking of and thinking about how
for me a notion of a self
as a kind of independent
yeah i was thinking about that like
independent how much that's you know
littered kind of all over the the
historical
political documentation of this
place not even the place it's not the
place it's the
the nation that you know like that that
kind of abstraction
of the united states um
and i feel and i feel like i've been so
incredibly attracted to interdependence
and something about
like being a part of these diasporas i'm
connecting to
joy that you're talking about
understanding that
there there was never any way for
me to and this has a lot to do with
actually how i think about
consent you know when i do um that there
was never any way for me to
be completely individuated from
everything else for
for and for a thing of me to be
completely individuated and i think
about
how how interdependent all of those
things
are and how it how in a given moment if
i
what you know what are what are the
possibilities if i you know
am am cell jumping energy
jumping fusing with this four-year-old
that i'm talking to and then we're
becoming for that moment of
uh uh uh whatever you know
uh a thing
and that that is you know that that has
the same kind of validity
and potential reform that
the any you know this kind of notion of
myself
could and does
and the same thing with you know like
the
i mean i always i tend to spend a lot of
time with trees
you know they do i mean they they they
they are cousins
um and thinking about just what what it
is that happens when i'm with them when
i'm away from them what that physical
proximity does what that kind of
concentration space is
when i tap into trees and when i'm in a
place that doesn't have them
um or where they're deep far beneath the
ground you know
what i can see
yeah i mean i i think that there's
something about that
there's something about that um
that ungraspability
of self that also interacts a lot with
my
notion of when i wa when we were talking
about receptive or i guess i i brought
that word in
receptiveness you know it doesn't it it
it doesn't feel like a one-way journey
and it also doesn't feel
like a an individual task it feels like
something that is very communal to be
to be generated um
if it's going to be really generated you
know and if it's not then it feels like
something else you know like i i think
that there's also
i think that there's plenty of um plenty
of uh
uh availability of receptivity
bottoming that that is something that is
something other
than uh
an agreement you know that that is
definitely something far from an
agreement
and then that that i don't even you know
for me i don't even like to
think about attaching those words
because it feels
i mean it's you know the the words that
anyway
yeah yeah i don't know yeah something
about that joy
i'm just i feel you i thought of
something
um which was
an essay that's on the internet of fred
milton
that's consent not to be a single being
[Music]
uh and i thought of that because you
were talking
about a few things but
i and then i just started thinking about
holes
um and black holes and
and yeah like
space and you know this
and maybe that's a bit of inception
because there's this
uh there's these things
i mean that we've touched on sort of
already always all the time
the darkness and fear and
and what's darkness and blackness um
[Music]
so i and also joy
and i was wondering if
what you were talking about because you
sort of went into this story
i guess i was curious juma about like
pleasure
and when you're talking about the trees
because i definitely felt like oh yeah
that's when i'm like
doing my plant medicine and i'm like
definitely like talking to some plants
and i'm like really feeling
you know feeling being you know it's not
i don't need to have a word
because i'm with a plant and with trees
or like other than human situations i
it seemed like there was a moment of
pleasure in there
and i wonder like as you were telling
the story and i
wonder if that was
if there is pleasure in that
trees moments or like somewhere in there
[Music]
i mean
god it's the yeah i'm i'm i'm feel you
know i'm feeling it and i reiterate i
mean i just get like
i'm so non-committal with words you know
like i'll say something
and you know like this just this
immediate thing that happens i'm like oh
that's not really what i mean
i don't dwell on it as much anymore but
just because it just feels like oh
the i don't want to waste everybody's
time with that but the yeah but i'm
thinking about this yeah
pleasure um
the i i will i will
yes i will uh i will ex i will i will
receive that i will accept that word
i think there is something sublime
um i think that there is
there is something physical you know i
think that they're there you know that
that
that feels um
and i've also like i'm having
personally like you know and i guess
professionally because so much of my
work has to do with sex and sexuality
and sensuality
i'm feeling like i'm going through
something in that
all of those realms i've been like
i guess like celibate for maybe a year
and something
which i guess is you know it's it's
while being celibate you know i feel
like i've had sex twice and then
realized
you know during that like oh yeah i'm
still celibate
[Laughter]
um it i
think that there is something uh
there is something that that complex
matrix network of myself
is trying to work out with themselves
that um
that i'm not that i feel like i can't
really invite other folks
other folks into other kind of networks
of selves into
right now and i do you know i mean and i
have like
i feel like so so it so it in terms of
uh
i think i think it has something to do
with
it has something to do with pleasure it
has something to do with
trying to work around my way around
again to
uh uh prioritizing my own pleasure i
feel like pleasure is a priority in my
life and i feel like
guidance toward pleasure for me for
other selves you know
that feels something like something so
central and there is something that i'm
working on with my own pleasure
where it feels like a little bit
obscured right now
um
and i'm and i'm yeah and i'm and i'm
trying to i'm trying to figure that out
so it doesn't
feel like being with other beings and
like you know with like these cousin
trees
it doesn't feel like that is
that it doesn't feel like the answer is
there and i don't know where it is yet
you know um i feel like it was to me
like since sometimes but
but but i can't you know i can't hold on
to it you know because how do you hold
on to the air and i'm an air sign too
and so it's like you know i'm just like
oh god this makes
so much sense jesus um
there's beauty i feel like there's a
beauty also like it's just
like having access to some something
beauty which just feels like so huge
inside of being with the truth oh my
gosh and there's these like
i'll be in uh i'm gonna be out of town
out of the country
in a little bit and the in one of the
places i'll be is with
these these places with like these trees
with these long exposed
roots
just feels like oh my gosh you're just
like to just to be so kind of like you
know i don't know is it naked
or is it you know just exposed and
it just feels like such a i don't know i
i feel like there is something
i need to be there to understand is this
vulnerability that i'm seeing you know
these exposed roots is it
is it um
i i don't know anyway yes yeah yeah
something about that i don't i think
that i i i know i said pleasure so i
think that i talked about something that
you were asking about doing
a little bit all over the place but yeah
wha
i'm curious now too like where do you
tommy please let you know i don't want
to hijack anything but i'm
i'm curious from to know from you
especially since you're bringing it into
this space
what is your kind what what's your
what's your
how do you how do you navigate through
the the the maps you know like how do
you navigate through your maps to to
locate your pleasure what's that kind of
navigation process like for you
yes please
hey
joy joy
joy joy
yes i'm trying to write down your
your um formulated list of mapping
pleasure
i'm trying to get the direct download
is it on the internet somewhere
i'm like isn't everything these days
that came up the other day are we on the
internet now is that where we
actually are or one of the places we are
is the internet like a mycelium
what is mycelium
like spores and and [ __ ]
hmm i do love technology
is it is it because of displacement
is that one of the reasons
i think i think it has i think it has
something to do with confusion
you know it it uh
it feels like the
especially i feel like especially in
thinking about the internet you know
like that kind of
obsessed pool of information it feels
like
i feel like it confuses and um
confuses and and that the and i don't
have any kind of you know
i don't i don't use that as like a bad
word but you know it confuses
truth uh no it confuses a singularity of
truth
uh
i feel like i'm kind of following in a
way
and also uh really
thinking about zakiyah jackson's um
becoming human and in like the next to
last chapter she's talking about how
black life is always bound up and being
disoriented
and we're you know we're pretty good at
being disoriented since it's
a kind of basic tenet of being a black
person on the planet
so then that confusion of space
uh it's familiar so we have you know
maybe strategies
and i don't think that jackson offers it
like a good or bad
like i wouldn't make it that tiny um
but there's something about being
compelled epigenetically like before
birth
to be like the animals we were talking
about
um predisposed to handle disorientation
in certain kinds of ways that maybe
is part of what makes it seem as though
we can do all the work
because we've actually been you know in
some ways
burst into a social system
that expects us to be able to do the
work the labor of pleasure
the labor of spirit the labor of
political activism
the labor of literal labor of building
the railroad
um or cleaning down the the classrooms
under covid so that the other folks can
you know sit and take their theory
course
so something in there about like
um
an ability to to negotiate and navigate
but also as an expectation that i'm
wondering
at um because i'm sure
you know i imagine that you know each of
us have been
tasked with being able to handle
[ __ ] that you know we didn't want to
handle it either but there it is
it's like somebody's got to do it so
then who who who is going to actually do
it
well the people who actually are already
born into being able to
navigate confusion and cesspools
hi william
thanks um
i just wanted i thought of like 30
things while you were talking
um and let's see
which of those things come out of my
mouth
somehow
yeah i'm still like hooked into juma's
tree thing
but then i had a really vivid memory
of learning how to walk through the
forest
uh in total darkness
and also like okay so
also being educated in a time where
there was no internet
and then uh and then there was
so having a split experience of
educational spaces
um and how information
but when the screen sort of came
and it still happens i i just made a
joke the other day
where i said
that max were racist
because the setting on the camera of a
mac
like can't perceive my [ __ ] blackness
it's so annoying like it's never
right and then if i'm trying to be slick
and use the sexy zoom
background i i'm like a ghost which is
definitely something that i'm gonna like
work with as material because it's just
there's just too much there to not
um but making jokes all the time about
like
being on screen and also looking back
and also carrying with my ancestors this
like
jokes upon jokes about being black and
the dark and
being seen or not being seen um
which is definitely a trope but how how
what spaces i use that in and i just
started
i mean tommy you were there at
times congress with
oh [ __ ] i can't remember this person's
name but
did like a black dark workshop
that was nigel whitson yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so that was awesome uh
and i thought about like how many times
in my life
i was in scenarios where blackness and
darkness were sort of conflated in a way
that felt violent
and then when i sort of took the reins
there and used
blackness and darkness and
intentionally conflated them
uh to as a as the skill
as part of my magic as part of my power
as also like understanding
how darkness can be used
um when darkness's protection
and freeing and who said what to whom
that made darkness scary or bad
um so the memory that i got when joomla
was talking about these exposed
roots is is taking pleasure i mean like
growing up in philly was not
like i was deeply going into the forest
like
now that i live in europe there's a lot
of uh
stories of romanticized and maybe
horrific
stories of going into the woods and
xyz happens i didn't have that as a
child
um i was like going to the parking lot
so at the same time i didn't
when i had the through the few trees
that i was around as a child
which are definitely now condos um
uh i would go walking through these
through trees and i would
i would take such pleasure in being
enveloped in
the darkness of the woods and then later
as an adult are actually quite recently
learning like using these moon cycles
when the moon is
waning from full to new
to understand how to walk through the
forest and just walk through the forest
at the full moon and
do that all the way to the new moon
it's out it's like amazing
and i'm sort of like what is this like
feeling like i can
still see but knowing like what is
seeing or perception
and and and feeling sort of like the
things that exist
i think there's also working with like
understanding the shadow self and how to
use that
um those are things like
when i'm sort of enveloped in darkness
in nature outside and
when that that feels comfortable
um is definitely like makes me question
of like
who taught me when to be uncomfortable
with darkness and why um
so now i'm sort of in a zone
where i'm looking at darkness
and and blackness and pleasure
as like sites of
uh extreme power and
extreme comfort
and again sort of joomla like you were
saying about
celibacy um
well how i how i'm making a connection
is like
trying to remember you said celibacy and
then you sort of
link that to an understanding or a
focus of not being busy with
sights or moments of pleasure with other
but like
really having an a focus on self and
your own understanding
um with yourself and maybe not even
multiple selves with a self
uh i think this is also
sort of what i'm doing but
in the dark now that sounds like
i don't give a [ __ ] how that sounds
because i like actually
i give zero [ __ ] of how that sounds
because i
probably mean it in all the ways it can
be meant
so i just wanted to say
somehow that's also related
um and i want to name that
just because i'm operating in the dark
or doing smooth moves in the dark
doesn't mean i am trying to blur
any boundaries or trying to obscure
boundaries or
trying um when i talk about envelopment
it's because i think then you get into
the tricky
consent la la las which we don't need to
talk about
um and it's also related to some of the
research i'm doing in
in dark rooms dark room spaces
um yeah it's just like what is that
i don't need to name what it is but
there's a feeling
that i get where
i don't i'm not busy with trying to
understand
how i can navigate like maybe it's in my
dna that i
have skills walking the earth in the
dark
that would make sense maybe it's magic
also fine um maybe
maybe i'm like part cheetah like who
cares
um and i think it's funny like when i
hang out with ash who is
totally black and it's dark in my room
because i
don't have any lights because i'm
particular
but when it's dark and we're in my room
together like
how we see each other is really
interesting and how i can tell where she
is because of
the absence of light is really
interesting to like
move towards like i'm not afraid to move
towards
a void or i'm not afraid to move towards
an
unknown especially if it's ash because
i'm like oh i know that
um so let's play together and
she's a cat so she can definitely see me
that was like all kinds of everywhere
i feel like that's also fine so good
exactly we're moving towards like
you know zoom limiting so boundaries of
zoom there are some i think
but i really did want to like propose
queer futures in queer reproduction
um there's a way and this was really not
planned but it kind of just emerged
there was a kind of way that
in the first day of this this trio of
days
um we were chatting about present and
like
how are you you know how you be and
present and then
there was a way that yesterday we were
spending a lot of
time thinking about time and 20 000
years ago
and and and how we're still then we are
then
and so i wanted to kind of propose to
the two of you
or the many of yous uh this question
about reproductive
what's what how how does queer reproduce
like how do you you know
we we hinted that we see through birth
family in a certain kind of way
but what are other queer kinship sort of
futurings
that you're thinking about or busy with
or
wondering at
in relationship in relationship to that
about
this you know these wonderings about
future
and queer futures and reproduction
i'm thinking also joy about
the at some point you were talking about
how you learn to walk
in the darkness in the woods or maybe in
the woods in the darkness i don't
remember what the order was
um
i taught it i taught for 10 years at
swarthmore college
um
and during one of my colleagues's
retirement
kind of ceremonies there was this person
this older person
from who came out out to swarthmore from
philly
who i don't remember why we started
talking but somehow we just started
talking
and then uh this person asked if um
i think was asking about my like where
am i where the offices are and i was
like oh yeah well my office is it's a
shared office it's down in the basement
and they were like oh yeah let's go see
it and so we went down there to go see
my office
and um and there was uh
the i feel very sensitive to like the
overhead fluorescent lights
i don't really like them so much so i'll
always you know i'll kind of
throw open the office door and befo
while it's closing go
make my way around all the kind of
chairs stuff into the office to the lamp
at the back of the room to turn it on
before the door closes so that i can see
because it's there's no windows
in there um so i was kind of going
through that choreography
while this person came into my office
and there were a couple of maybe like
three or four seconds while we were in
the darkness while i was fumbling to
find the light
and then i turned it i turned it on and
this person was there just kind of like
staring at me
and they were like you need to spend
more time in the darkness
and that is really you know that's
really
that's really stuck with me there were
also these drums in the office they were
they were like oh yeah you need to spend
time with in the darkness with these
drums and just feeling um
and it feels like it has a lot of the
i think that i'm getting to the end of a
choreographic project that i've been
working on with um
a colleague of mine named dante beacham
for the past decade
and a lot of the most
recent part of that work has had to do
with
moving into backspace moving behind
ourselves
walking behind ourselves crawling behind
ourselves moving into
the unknown and how to do that moving
into
the darkness and how how to
how to balance like a a
a mission an objective with
all of this unknown that already exists
just because you don't just because i
don't maybe know it it
it's it you know it's there and there's
a certain
and then for me you know i kind of lean
on you know there's a certain kind of
faith that i need there's a certain kind
of
acceptance of this kind of
interdependency that i need there's a
certain kind of care
that i need to do so that i that i need
to have so that i can
care for myself and care for the
what's there in the in the unknown and
there are some things that i have
assumptions like you know like if i'm
doing a kind of controlled
moving backward exercise in a studio and
i know that you know dante and maria are
with me and if i can't
see them with my eyes and in this kind
of front and peripheral space
i can assume that they're in my unknown
you know like
in this backspace in this darkness you
know in this behind
um but that they're there but that
they're there and i'm caring for them in
the ways that i
know them the way that i assume them the
way that i don't know them
and it feels like there's
reproduction i've been thinking a lot
about reproduction
lately yeah i don't think i'll talk
about that publicly
other than saying that but um
it does i do feel like there is
something about
this belief in care
for the unknown this faith in the
unknown
um and also a trusting in it a trusting
that you know that
that that care can move both ways
something about that that feels i don't
know necessarily
does it feel like
i think that's something about the uh
the lack of easy or immediate definition
that that has in the definition in terms
of like a kind of clear languaging in
terms of like uh
you know like uh being able to assess a
clear kind of form
you know immediate you know like
something about that kind of lack of
definition
makes it feel like that process there is
something there is something that is
that there's something that is queer
about that process of approaching
future and it also it also feels like
it's you know it is
needy if i could think about that word
as detached from like you know these
kinds of
uh uh negative associations with the
pejorative associations with
but there's something about it that is
needed you know the
there is
if i'm thinking about doing this on my
own by myself then it feels like that's
already
it's not the wrong path it feels like
maybe it's already a reason to
to to to be still
to to steal that you know distill that
for a moment
before
to still what i don't know to still what
i mean like it's like
i mean i feel like time is you know it
it's always happening
so i don't what is the what is the
stealing
anyway this quietness is also like that
that quiet you know and maybe that's
still maybe they're
related but you know but that quiet
also feels important and i feel so
so aware of that in this pandemic moment
when there's you know
so frequently i'll you know i'll just
need to have like a
the one in the netflix series play all
throughout the day just so that there's
some
noise because sometimes the quiet that
space that is so abundant
feels overwhelming and i can't deal with
all of that possibility
i need to have something that is maybe a
little bit prescribed for me you know in
in some certain moments
that i don't so that
so that i don't have to deal with the
freedom of losing myself you know
um
are the zoom police gonna kick us out
they they are not um i just um have
i have zoom practices
that um yeah but we're good
okay i because i respect and value
everyone's times so
um if if there is
like people need to leave i
feel like that's fine i also am not
terribly aware of time because
i'm so in a different time zone that i'm
like what
but i did want to talk about this
reproduction thing
uh plus one that i have also been
thinking about reproduction
not gonna name that also like joomla
however what is interesting to me so
what also pops into my head is uh
i don't know what y'all are doing over
here but in
overly relaxed netherlands
um there's like clearly the second wave
is happening
and before that although not visually
but like if you
look at the math um
before that happened i was like okay
like
i'm relatively aware i just sent an
email
um i do like queer public service
announcements via email
where i just like pick a bunch of people
and i send them some stuff
uh sometimes it's what i'm thinking
sometimes it's porn
whatever whatever and in this case i was
like hey y'all
uh i'm thinking about
what i don't want to do uh just if you
want to follow the thread in my mind or
one of the many
i'm linking to joomla's like oh by
myself all the time i'm gonna do
la la la like that's clearly
um i don't wanna like
be i wanna say wrong or not the right
path but by myself
is not something that is serving me at
the moment
so in thinking about
when i was anticipating another wave
because i
know what a pandemic is
which means it's a you got to take the
long view anyway
and you have to take a long view into
the unknown
so i really just want to like you know
like double snap to like
black folks minoritarians oppressed
people that
already have this skill set of
trying to like a vast unknown or like
not having
access to la la la um we might not
already know how to do
some of that um
people that have experienced war or
things uh
so i was like yeah like i
talked to an elder and i was like um
yeah i don't want to
i don't i don't want to like get into
this capitalistic
white supremacist like oh i need to
improve myself
like and be more productive now during
the pandemic like i need to come out
better than i
i need to emerge bionic [ __ ] all that
i was like what are we doing um
who do who who do we need to be around
what's what are our strategies what are
our resources
what do you need what do i need um
like where's my escape hatch if i need
to [ __ ] off to an island somewhere
what does that look like who can i
cuddle with
like really just being i think also like
queer poc
polly like all these like sexual
strategies
all these things that um
in certain institutions or like we don't
talk about those things
but those skills that we already have
actually help us navigate the time we're
in now
so when i think about reproduction it's
like
uh the the being with and the sort of
sitting in an unknown
and and connecting
like putting a lot of energy into
how i'm connecting and the
intentionality around
those connections and also shift my
understanding of
reproduction similarly as i shifted my
understanding of
production um um
just like if you're like following along
that there was already
a mention of like work rest
relationship it's like okay like
yeah what's kinship what's reproduction
what am i trying to reproduce what
what is what are the bonds that i need
or long for and
how am i if all that's moving around um
how do i sustain that um
[Music]
and maybe it has something to do with
darkness
full stop
no such a thing as full stop huh
but there is
joy black joy right here and and
gracious um a gracefulness towards your
generosity
and a thank you um
we pause and shift uh to you know to
acknowledge the work that william and
hercules
are up to it matters that you know they
get a break
if they need it and also that um
people can re-uh adjust to their
relationship to the screen and all of
that sort of thing
it's a a remarkable conversation i thank
you so much
i want to invite everybody who's still
on the call to unmute
and say say ad you and thank you and and
more please soon um as you will
to the panelists and also just obviously
sort of commend lion's jaw to keep
making platforms for experimental
thinking
experimental being reconsiderings of
reorientations and queer futurity
so we can kind of be in the space of
figuring ourselves
out among each other um with some sort
of grace and some sort of love
so it unmuted thank you thank you
thank you thank you so much thank you
thank you
for three amazing days thank you so much
thank you
you